want to talk about oculus of course the
PlayStation VR is launching really soon
that later this week but oculus connect
was later this earlier this week and
Jimmy you were down south you were down
south in California checking us out yeah
it was actually late last week and it
was a three-day event in San Jose
California where they revealed the touch
pricing which is their motion track
controllers and we've seen the touch
controllers before it's like they're a
much nicer version of tracking
controllers than we've seen for other
controller [ __ ] in line with what the
vibe has right it is in line with what
the vibe has I would say it's actually
more ergonomic even very comfortable to
hold basically inside VR games it takes
the shape of your hands I feel like the
vibe controllers are more like something
that you hold for the most part they
represent like a sword or something like
that but the pricing is what was the new
thing how much do ya so it's coming out
December sixth and it's going to be
retailing for 109 199 dollars which is
for free for both controllers it's not
like that's not like Warner dollars for
the purge and roller so it comes a lot
though it's still a lot of comes with an
additional sensor which you'll need for
a wider kind of camera fov still though
it doesn't provide room scale
experiences out of the box for that
you'll need to buy a third sensor which
costs $79 so when you say like a room
scale VR experience what does that mean
so room scale is a basically a mode in
VR that allows you to like walk around
your living room space most VR games
have you either sitting down or
sometimes to have like standing
experiences like I think PlayStation VR
really tackles that front sitting seated
and standing yeah generally when you see
people playing these we are games you're
you're just kind of sitted seated in
front of your TV but when you see people
playing on the vibe they have the
cameras set up and it's a much more
elaborate setup but it does allow you to
walk around and so this will allow the
vibe to be more room scale to let you
walk around in that space yes and you
know with the third sensor you're going
to be able to have this thing that they
call the Guardian system and that
basically you can map out your
environment so with envy are when you're
effectively blindfolded you can kind of
see where
walkable space is like there'll be like
a blue grid that pops up when you get
too close to a wall so it's not destiny
related then different guardian uh right
okay um and so yes it's going to be two
hundred dollars plus effectively tuna
dollars plus the headset which is six
hundred dollar sets basically Anna
dollars the price of the vibe and then
also the third sensor to make it a
routine you want to get the room that
third sensor to get rim scale then it's
going to be close to 880 so it sounds
like in order to achieve what vive
already offers it's about eighty dollars
more is that correct mathematically yes
but good do so I spoke to jason rubin
about and asked about about the pricing
because i think it was to get room
skills more expensive than than i
thought and i imagine what most people
thought um but he said like yeah it is
technically a little bit more expensive
but they throw in like an Xbox
controller they throw in like a remote
are they throwing like some games and
things like that so he thinks it's
pretty comparable and while it is
expensive I was able to play about a
half dozen games or so and I was that
was really blown away yeah there were
some specific games that you thought
were really good and things that we
haven't some that we have played before
on other vr consoles or that we played
on oculus and some that were brand new
right yeah there are three in particular
that I played that really impressed me
the first one is a game that is
technically out now but the version i
played was retrofitted or basically
redone to working vo and that was super
hot VR which is a really good game on
itself yeah I haven't played the
original on pc air our consoles but I
felt like from what I played it's a game
that's like tailor-made for VR so the
premise is there or it's a first person
shooter for the most part even though
you can't punch and things like that as
well and for whatever reason there's
these like red polygonum goons that are
out to kill you and they can do so by
the punching you or shooting you and
when they hit you once either by a fist
or a bullet you die and it takes place
in a very kind of white environment and
in the real game when you move the
controller that's when things start
moving like if somebody shoots a bullet
at you the bullet is actually moving
towards you until you start moving
I assume in VR like you have to either
stand Stockstill or when you move in VR
that's when the action starts occurring
around yeah so the the gimmick is that
when you stand still bullets and things
like that and your enemies move very
very slowly as soon as you start to move
that's when like the speed kicks up and
so it's a constant like juggling act of
when do I move slow and when do I move
fast you know and you can also disarm
your opponents so if they're holding a
gun you can like quickly reach out and
grab the gun and shoot them back and
there are multiple levels within the
game and then with within each level
there are multiple stages so I think for
the most part they had like four or five
stages within a level and that's say you
made it to the fourth or fifth stage if
you died on that stage you have to start
the whole entire level all over again so
this kind of puts you in a sort of trial
and error kind of mode but normally I
hate that but for this game I actually
really admired it it made you sort of
remember back to like okay what is this
next scenario going to entail and then
you might remember like okay to my right
there's going to be a goon with a gun so
I quickly grabbed his gun then like
maybe shoot him there's gonna be a goon
to my left I'll have to shoot him and
then I'll have no bullets left then I
have to grab the bottle in front of me
then I'll have to chuck it down at the
opponent running towards me down the
hallway so well the other two games you
played were new experiences these
weren't things that we'd play before
right lone echo and yeah the unspoken
yes so lone echo is like a sci-fi Space
Exploration game it's made by ready at
dawn and I think they made some of the
uncharted games the Honorable the mobile
little boy yeah I think naughty dog
media should the PSP stuff um and yeah
so do the order 1886 yeah I think so so
there's like a single-player component
which has you controlling a robot named
Jack and that game has you floating
around a space station what makes that
game interesting is how you traverse the
environment so there is no unlike many
other VR games there's no teleportation
you actually just float around through
space and normally things like that tend
to make people including myself motion
sick but I didn't experience really any
motion sickness how they're doing it is
like when you float around you can like
grab onto objects and
walls in the environment and push off
and there are also thrusters on your
robot risks that allow you to like move
forward so you just aim like where you
want to go by pointing your wrist in the
right direction so there was that but
what really made the experience really
fun for me was the multiplayer which is
I guess a cross between rocket League
Tron and though I haven't read it
ender's game so what it what it is is a
5v5 game in a spaceship and you have
like a Tron like disc that you're trying
to get into the goal and you also have
to play against 12 year olds yes
although fortunately when I was an
oculus connect I was playing with like
nine other people from the press or
whatever strangers worse strangers that
I didn't know we're all in different
rooms but it felt like we were all like
floating in the spaceship together and
we were just hilariously laughing and
shouting at each other and I remember
this is one point so there's another
mechanic in the game where you can grab
an opponent and you can punch him in the
face and that kind of like puts him out
for like two seconds they can't move so
I remember there was one part where i
had when i had the disc and it was
flying towards their goal but i was a
little too high so i communicated
towards my teammate that there was
somebody behind me and i was going to
pass it to them and my teammate was
headed right towards the goal and I was
like okay I'm gonna pass it to you right
now and I pass it to him and he's like
slowly floats up to the goal has the
thing Chuck's it and he misses and I'm
like you had one job so I'm like scream
at him it sounds like rocket League yeah
yeah so that game was a really awesome
and the last one was the unspoken which
sounds like a horror game the unspoken
is a 1v1 wizard doing game so not not
quite [ __ ] it's not it's not really a
horror game uh it does sound like that
though so in that game you know all
these games use the touch controllers
and in that game you can if you're like
the fire caster you can hold down the
right trigger to like form a fireball in
hand you can like chuck at I people with
your left or like non-dominant hand you
can hold down the left trigger to like
form a temporary shield that you can
bounce balls back and then there are
like fancier other gestures that you can
do like you can cross your arms hold
down the triggers wait for a timer to
appear and then like chuck them at the
ground and then like a giant you know
shield like temporary shield will block
all incoming
X and you could do other like fancy hand
gesture so like summon monsters and
things like that from what I hear from
other developers who have played the
game they say there's a lot of depth to
that game and it's actually gonna be
shipping with touch controls for free
and all of these announcements these
games that you played was it oculus
connect and I don't think the timing was
a coincidental that this is also around
the time of the PlayStation launching
this is set of course a little bit
further ahead of time but this is their
chance to make a statement because
oculus is an HTC have both been out
there for a while a PlayStation is still
the newer I it hasn't launched yet
people all not as many people have tried
it out where do you think oculus stands
now that they've been on the market for
a while this is their chance to to react
to the Playstations launch as its Sun
coming so like for me personally I think
I've been pretty critical of what oculus
has been doing I think they were kind of
wrong the messaging of the initial price
point mmm they said that was gonna be in
the ballpark of 350 ended up being like
600 and then the touch controls are like
another 200 and it's more it's the most
expensive a room scale set up and there
was a couple other things there their
initial drm issues and things like that
that people didn't really like um did so
that they turn it around with oculus
connect I think so um I think coming
into the event if you were to ask me and
I think we did actually do a lobby
segment on this which my favorite VR
headset was I would have said they HTC
vive pretty confidently no I don't know
um it's tough because the games the
first wave of oculus games were kind of
oh no they weren't great um they were
kind of hidden mists and the kind of
some of them felt like tech demos these
games that I played felt really fun and
polished and it definitely felt like the
second wave of VR games it was there any
talk about going beyond games because
for me that's also a really interesting
part of the art it's more than just
gaming yeah so they had the oculus
connect keynote in which Mark Zuckerberg
CEO of facebook took to the stage and he
talked about some of the social aspects
and yeah so you'll be able to like make
calls in dr that video is kind of gone
viral a little bit of him calling his
wife and dr and taking like a selfie
which is pretty trippy your own avatars
one thing that we kind of talked
talked about it off camera earlier today
is it's a very weird experience meeting
somebody in VR because you feel because
I think when you have the headset
strapped on in a single player scenario
it's kind of like this make-believe
environment and it feels immersive
enough but there's a part of your brain
that says like this is still fake but
then when you have somebody else in that
same environment corroborating what
you're seeing it suddenly becomes much
more real and tangible something we've
seen a lot with the PlayStation VR
experiences even the the multiplayer
ones or that they're still very
traditional from a from a game
perspective whereas oculus it did feel
like their experiences made specifically
for virtual reality in that when you're
interacting with somebody like they're
there across the table from you you know
you're both wearing a headset but it
feels more real because yes you can you
forget that you are um sometimes so you
know I'll be like follow me I'm gonna
toss the disc at you like go to my
lawyer right and then you know I'll toss
the thing out you know I'll point I'd be
like go you know go down there and then
I'll chuck it out you out as I faked
going to the left and you totally forget
that you're in this cubicle thing
wearing this headset mm-hmm so what do
you think PlayStation and HTC's next
moves are going to be like oculus is for
you setting that that standard
PlayStation is just about to launch but
what do they need to do next what is HTC
need to do to respond so i think HTC
they have a bunch of games a lot lots of
them are self-aware unfortunately some
of them are are good but they're low
budget and I wish valve or HTC invested
a little bit more money until into
polishing up those titles I think oculus
is getting a lot of hate because of its
exclusive content but at the same time
on the flip side and you know oculus
could argue that without their funding
those games wouldn't be made um so
there's that and then I think on PSP our
side I think a lot of the games there
are some fun games I think like super
hyper cube i think it's called is really
fun and then thumpers really good as
well I feel though that those games can
be retrofitted to work on a traditional
monitor so I feel like on PS VRS front I
think they need more compelling content
is geared towards VR and Scott I know
you didn't go to oculus connect
obviously but you've been playing a bit
of the the VR content as well as have
you sold on any reviewed a couple of the
PS VR games yeah and I played a bunch of
five earlier in the year and I mean I
certainly agree with Jimmy that a lot of
what we're seeing are sort of
traditional games not necessarily
designed for VR but still being
implemented in VR like I just reviewed
game called battlezone what's to trounce
1980 and it's a cockpit tank game and
obviously cockpits work great in VR I
mean you have a sort of physical space
around you there's a clear explanation
for why you're not moving right you're
just seated and that's still like it
allows your brain to become more
immersed in what's happening around
you've seen tons of cockpit games as a
result but yeah you're still very
disconnected from the people around you
even in battle zone where you are
playing with other people it's a co-op
game you just sort of see their tank off
in the distance and yeah you can kind of
communicate in ways that you you maybe
couldn't in a traditional multiplayer
space but for the most part it is still
just you know a very traditional take on
like vehicle combat right so I'm more
intrigued by stuff like you know what
Mark Zuckerberg was doing and talking
about the social aspects that are
possible to be hard that to me is way
more intriguing and exciting than
anything we've seen as far as games go I
mean some of the games have been totally
fine but again like could probably work
just as well outside of er I mean there
really hasn't been a killer app in my
mind in terms of games that really sells
me on any of this hardware oh well we're
going to be talking a lot more about
games later on in the show of course
oculus connect all I think VR itself is
just on the cusp it's just beginning
it's just getting started we're going to
learn a lot more if you want to read
more about virtual reality games about
virtual reality systems stay tuned to
gamespot com